this morning Pat I was on the reddit
discussion forum for the David Pakman
show as I often am in the morning david
pakman.com slash reddit some interesting
discussions there that i'll put up on
the screen for our TV and youtube
audience that you can participate in if
you want there was a post about the
genesis of hatred mail as we know it and
a viewer dug back into the YouTube
archives to find the original hatred
mail where I had I said I've got a hate
mail that has been read by a deep voice
movie announcer type guy and that type
guy a deep voice movie announcer guy and
if people like this maybe we can make it
a regular thing so there's a lot of
discussion about the origins of Patriot
mail which are almost as mysterious as
the origins of the universe I'm finding
out based on this discussion that took
place did you see this one not yet but
you got all of that smiling face in the
screenshot there you can tell that the
David in that picture doesn't know what
hatred mail is going to is going to come
yeah that's absolutely right all right
also from our reddit discussion forum
red versus blue so stupid yet makes
total sense a very interesting post that
has generated discussion about
polarization of politics in the United
States I encourage you to check that out
also from our reddit discussion forum
thoughts on cobb feffy tweet and of many
people wanting to weigh in on their
thoughts there I won't add my thoughts
now since we've been talking about it
already but if you're looking to talk
about confessing as clearly many people
are you can do that on our reddit
discussion forum it is interesting to
question how it happened you know was
the up late tweeting and then fell
asleep nobody place anyone's guess at
this point and and you know we're
certainly not getting answers from Sean
Spicer also from our reddit discussion
forum there will be a debate between now
this is amazing this is we're going like
three levels deep okay there's the David
Pakman show
there's the David Pakman show reddit
discussion forum some participants on
the David Pakman show reddit discussion
forum have created a David Pakman show
discord server where viewers and
listeners can actually talk to each
other secular talk with Kyle kolinsky
has their own discord server and what
apparently has
been organized with none no involvement
for me no involvement from pat that I'm
aware of but I'll talk to him about that
affair Pat not now
there is going to be a debate between
David Pakman show discord server
participants and secular talk with Kyle
kolinsky discord server participants so
we're like in in in a sort of Inception
situation here where we're like four
layers deep in terms of political
debates happening and this is on the
significance of the Trump Russia
investigation I I guess they thought
about that but they're going in a
different direction now I'm not really
sure yeah in any case that's happening
and I think we've got one more reddit
discussion forum yes someone put up a
picture of what the experience of
becoming a david pakman show member was
like for them and you see me with a sort
of elated smile with the screenshot that
they said represented how they felt when
they got a David Pakman show membership
which is cool you look like a six year
old who's being asked to face cheese
reclass photo exactly so if you're not
seeing the visuals for what we're
talking about here definitely check it
out at david pakman.com slash read it
we've got close to I think we're closing
in on 4,000 of our viewers and listeners
participating there